Number one, I have come across some suggestions of different B vitamins and things to add to someone
with Parkinson's disease. Is this something you would recommend and have you follow that Parkinson's
can be reversed? Well, that's the top question. Parkinson's can't be reversed. Parkinson's is typically
immune attack. Many times it auto-beaut attack part of the brain called the substantiate
nigra, which is the deep in the mid-brain. That's the only part of the brain that makes dopamine
and dopamine as essential as an amino acid as under a transmitter for smoothed out movements
as far as its connection with frontal motor cortex and the cerebellum.
And a deficiency in dopamine leads to a disease called Parkinson's disease.
Can taking supplements help? Yeah, cleaning up your diet could help. Decreasing the brain
inflammation is probably your best help. Supporting through typically for the medical intervention
is medication that's going to replace dopamine. But problem is that tends to only last for a
period of a couple of years and then it just doesn't work as well anymore. So it's a progressive
disorder and there is a data magic medicine that is going to cure Parkinson's. However, what has been
found is that inflammation in the brain is at least a contributor to it. That in fact you can
test for neural antibodies and get a pretty good idea that you have a possibility of early
Parkinson's or you could catch it at an early stage and you could start doing some things about it.
So the test that you would test for that would be a Cyrex array 7x which would test for neural
antibiotics. It's not a perfect test but it's a good indicator. All sorts of different inflammatory
markers that have caused antibodies to neural tissue that you can now start to make
interventions. Usually people only do that test after they have neural symptoms
meaning some upper motor neurons symptoms, some early Parkinson's, some early dementia.
Though it would be better to do it before you have those symptoms that you can start to be more proactive.
However, what do you do with that if that's positive? What do you do if you already have a Parkinson's
diagnosis? Well, you have to decrease brain inflammation. That's your number one purpose. You
got to find sources that are causing an increase in inflammation in the brain. So
decreasing brain inflammation, you think of different nutritional supplements like
flavonoids, curcumin, Boswellia, stinging dental, that kind of thing, Chorsatin. Those are the
fluids that can help increase brain inflammation. But if you have a source that's causing an increase
in inflammation, you're going to want to go with that. If you don't decrease that source. So
dealing with a food sensitivity is gluten is the most cutting that's going to cause brain inflammation
certainly dairy, other food sensitivity could cause that. Looking at tests to measure blood
brain barrier permeability issues and working on that and improving that can be beneficial,
increasing oxygenation to the brain. One of the best things that I've seen for people with Parkinson's
is to do hyperbaric chamber. The negative of that is you have to do it on a regular basis,
meeting daily. So it's almost better to have a hyperbaric chamber in your house.
Certainly different supplements can be beneficial, but I'd really concentrate on the anti-inflammatory
things with Parkinson's and I've really concentrated biting sources of inflammation.